structure we see it everywhere we look
in the universe from the elegant
tendrils of spiral galaxies to the
regular orbits of planets around a star
like our own to the DNA that carries the
code of life we see again and again that
nature creates larger structures from
collections of just a few smaller types
of components and this creates
tremendous variation billions of stars
are organized to make galaxies any
number of planets and stars come
together to form solar systems and so on
if we continue to shrink our scale we
see that nature continues for trend of
using modular constructs of just a few
simpler structures to create a truly
awesome and diverse universe in this
lecture we're going to discuss one of
the smallest systems that follows this
tenant indeed one of the smallest
systems in all of creation the atom it's
important to start our discussion by
pointing something out atoms actually
can be divided but doing so causes
something very special to happen that
doesn't happen when we divide larger
samples of elements take the example of
a bar of gold that bar of gold can be
cut in half to make two smaller bars of
gold
those can be cut into smaller pieces as
well and they're still gold the process
can continue creating ever smaller and
smaller samples of that element gold but
if we could continue to do this
perpetually eventually we would arrive
at a point where we have just one atom
of gold left in our sample so what now
is that atom of gold truly indivisible
actually no it can be divided but in
doing so its identity changes the two
fractions created by splitting an atom
of gold are no longer gold there's
something else but this leads us to an
interest
question what are atoms themselves made
of if they can be split into other
smaller atoms then they must be made of
even smaller pieces of matter than atoms
themselves and in fact they are atoms
are comprised of just three types of
particles called subatomic particles
positively charged protons negatively
charged electrons and neutrons which
have no charge at all protons and
neutrons are of nearly equal mass and
reside in a dense nucleus at the center
of the atom but much smaller negatively
charged electrons orbit that nucleus
balancing out the positive charge that's
provided by the protons most of us are
familiar with this depiction of the atom
but the story of how we came to
understand it is every bit as
fascinating as the structures own
elegance so today we're going to try to
understand how each of these particles
was discovered and how generations of
scientific work ultimately came together
to create our understanding of the most
fundamental unit of matter the atom the
notion of atoms was first forwarded by
ancient Greek philosophers who
postulated that there are just a handful
of fundamental substances now they
combine in various ways to form all
other substances the Greeks widely
believed these elements to be air water
earth and Fire
and they also believed that particles of
these elements were absolutely
indivisible of course today we know that
none of these things are actually
elements and we also know that atoms of
true elements can in fact be divided
just that they change into something new
when they are nonetheless the Greek term
atom literally meaning not divisible has
stuck and is still how we refer to the
smallest quantity of a given element
that can still exist as that element
Western disk
worse over the nature of matter and its
fundamental units slow to nearly a halt
with the fall of ancient Greece and it
wasn't until the start of the 19th
century that the concept of the atom was
revived primarily as a result of the
work of John Dalton Dalton didn't have
the sophisticated scientific instruments
that we do today so he had no way to see
or experiment directly on atoms what he
did have though was a keen intellect and
the benefit of the work of Lavoisier and
others using relatively simple
observations Dalton was able to
formulate a sound atomic theory based on
his observation let's begin by
considering a couple of reactions that
Dalton himself may have been able to run
and observe himself here's a molecule of
oxygen and we're going to react that
oxygen with two molecules of hydrogen
now when I do this I create water this
is a relatively simple reaction than one
that he could have run himself similarly
we can react oxygen with hydrogen but
instead have one oxygen react with one
hydrogen molecule and in this case we
create a different compound known as
hydrogen peroxide now Dalton could have
made both of these and he could have
determined the masses of his starting
materials and his products so let's say
that he does this and he was able to
determine that when 32 grams of oxygen
react with four grams of hydrogen 36
grams of water are produced this is
known as the law of conservation of mass
because 32 plus 4 equals 36 and he could
similarly observe this when he made
peroxide let's say right in this case 32
plus 2 is equal to 34 grams so
consistently when any reaction was run
the mass of all the products was equal
to the masses of all the starting
materials so this is our law of
conservation of mass now there's one
more important observation that helped
him to nail down the atomic theory
notice that in this case we have 32
grams of oxygen
four grams of hydrogen in other words a
ratio of eight and in our lower reaction
we have a situation where 32 grams of
oxygen are reacting with two grams of
hydrogen for a ratio of about 16 and
notice that those two ratios themselves
are very simple whole number multiples
of one another in other words you either
can have a ratio of eight or a ratio of
16 which is double that but never in
between so Dalton noticed this and
coined this the law of multiple
proportions and it's the combination of
the law of conservation of mass and the
law of multiple proportions that gave
him an airtight argument for the
existence of indivisible atoms that come
together in these simple whole-number
ratios to create molecules so Dalton's
genius was to combine the laws of
conservation of mass and multiple
proportions to make an argument for the
existence of atoms it was the only
possible explanation for what he saw an
argument so strong that it finally
restored traction to the atomic theories
of Democritus and Plato Dalton himself
said matter though divisible in an
extreme degree is nevertheless not
infinitely divisible that is there must
be some point beyond which we cannot go
in the division of matter I have chosen
the word atom to signify these ultimate
particles but Dalton believed that he
had reached the end of the story in his
mind atoms were the ultimate particles
of matter and nothing smaller could
exist for his purpose is thinking of
atoms as indestructible unde ISEC double
pieces of matter worked we would have to
wait another century before technology
caught up with the atom leading to the
realization that the inner workings of
this remarkable construct of nature
depend on a complex but predictable
combination of even smaller particles
that we call subatomic particles
the first of these advances is one which
most of us are familiar with it has only
been a decade or so since that large
heavy nearly cube-shaped television set
finally gave way to the slim energy
sipping displays that adorn the walls of
your favorite big-box stores but the
technology on which these household
devices of the late 20th century were
based actually was devised much earlier
the cathode ray tube or CRT as it is
sometimes called was actually developed
at the end of the 19th century and it
played an important role in the
advancement of human understanding of
atoms
Thomson's cathode ray tube it was a
fairly simple evacuated glass - now this
tube contained two disks and those disks
were each connected to one terminal of a
battery creating an electrical voltage
across those two plates the negatively
charged plate would be called the
cathode and the positively charged plate
would be called the anode now when this
apparatus is constructed a beam of some
sort can be observed traveling from the
cathode to the anode and Thompson used
an anode with a small hole in the center
which allowed the beam to continue along
the body of the tube now here in this
environment he could study that beam
unperturbed of course the beam was
perfectly straight but Thompson noted
that when he placed charge plates at the
top and the bottom of that tube that the
beam bent ever so slightly in the
direction of the positive plate now this
told Thompson two important things about
what was making up his so-called cathode
ray first it had to be negatively
charged because the positive plate
attracted it this prompted him to name
these new particles electrons second and
maybe even more importantly the extent
to which the being curved allowed him to
estimate just how massive each electron
in the beam must be since larger
particles would necessarily
be deflected less by the charged plates
now using that cathode ray tube
JJ Thompson was able to create isolated
beams of pure electrons and measure
their mass velocity in charge his
measurements though led him to a
startling conclusion the electrons in
that beam were smaller than atoms
this led Thomson to propose the first
ever structural model for an atom more
than a hundred years after Dalton
repopulate the concept of atoms the
first real attempts to explain their
structure had finally been offered
Thomson postulated that atoms consisted
of the small negatively charged
electrons he had observed embedded in a
very low-density positively charged
spherical matrix making up the rest of
the atoms mass distributed throughout
that sphere a sketch of his model with
electrons peppered into a positively
charged sphere evokes images of raisins
in a bowl of pudding earning it the
moniker of Thompson's plum pudding model
but this first attempt to explain atomic
structure was short-lived as less than
two decades after Thompson proposed his
plum pudding model his own protege
Ernest Rutherford conducted an
experiment which was intended to build
on Thompson's model but instead
disproved it outright Rutherford is
credited with the discovery of what are
known as
alpha particles alpha particles are a
much larger charged particle more than a
thousand times larger than electrons and
they're created during the radioactive
decay of heavy elements like uranium but
Rutherford is not most famous for
discovering these particles he's most
famous for what he did with them next
Rutherford was curious to know how these
relatively large energetic alpha
particles would interact with atoms as
they passed through a thin foil of atoms
so he pointed a beam of alpha particles
at a piece of gold foil encircling the
foil in a special fluorescent screen
which would light up when struck by an
alpha
article assuming that Thompson's model
was correct the alpha particles were
expected to simply pass through the foil
being scattered only slightly if at all
as the experiment progressed Rutherford
noted that the brightest spot was
directly behind the gold foil just as he
expected but Rutherford was stunned when
he turned his attention to the other
side of the screen in the direction of
the source beam and saw that a few
particles were deflected almost directly
back toward the source clearly Thomson's
model could not be correct if the mass
of gold atoms was distributed across
their entire volume then there is no way
that an alpha particle could possibly be
reflected back towards its source by
those atoms they're simply not dense
enough
Rutherford's results strongly indicated
that atoms were made of mostly empty
space but with a highly concentrated
nucleus containing almost all of the
atoms mass in just a small fraction of
the atoms total volume this would
explain why on rare occasion an alpha
particle bounced back only an extremely
dense point of matter taking up a very
small volume of the atoms total could
possibly withstand the impact of an
alpha particle and cause it to ricochet
backwards in its original direction
Rutherford's own words probably best
described this he famously recounted of
his own experiment it was quite the most
incredible event that has ever happened
to me in my life it was almost as
incredible as if you had fired a 15-inch
shell at a piece of tissue paper and it
came back and hit you so there had to be
an extraordinarily dense but vanishingly
small point of mass at the center of
atoms very dense to explain the
ricocheting alpha particles and
vanishingly small to explain why just a
handful of those ricochets took place
during Rutherford's experiment
Rutherford realized then that atoms were
mostly made of empty space with that
dense point of matter at their centre
his model accounts for this and has been
dubbed the Rutherford model sometimes
also called the nuclear model because
it's the first to acknowledge that
most of an atom's mass resides in that
small dense nucleus at its center
so Rutherford had discovered that atoms
consisted of dense positively charged
nuclei surrounded by very light
negatively charged electrons but just
how small is a nucleus really now recall
that we've already learned just how
small atoms are having diameters of
about 100 Pico meters that's about one
tenth of a nanometer now Rutherford's
work eventually led to discovery that
the radius of a typical nucleus is only
about one one hundred thousandth that of
its electron cloud
that's one femtometer point zero zero
zero zero zero one nanometers now let's
put that into perspective that means
that if an atom were one meter across
its nucleus would be the size of a dust
mite if that same atom were as wide as a
football field the nucleus would be just
about a millimeter wide size of a grain
of sand and to get a nucleus the size of
that football field the atom would have
to be the size of planet Earth now if
you were an electron with an orbit the
size of Pluto looking back at the
nucleus it would appear to you like this
just a speck in the distance about the
size of our own Sun so Rutherford had
determined that massive positively
charged particles were concentrated in
the nucleus of the atom protons had been
discovered but there was one last bit of
observation to account for as research
on radioactivity continued there were
some observations about atomic nuclei
that were quite adding up in a very
literal sense
specifically researchers had irradiated
beryllium with alpha particles to
produce a new kind of radiation one that
didn't bounce back off of the nuclei the
way Rutherford's alpha particles did but
instead crashed into them with force
penetrating deep inside and knocking
protons out of the target atoms that
they struck the
to understanding these unusual
observations came in 1932 when James
Chadwick formerly a student of one of
Rutherford's own assistants completed
the inventory of subatomic particles
Chadwick reasoned that this newly
discovered radiation was able to
penetrate other atomic nuclei better
because it was uncharged whereas alpha
particles used by Rutherford carried
positive charge and were repelled by the
positive nuclei of the atoms they struck
this explains their tendency to ricochet
and bounce back but these new particles
though massive were able to get deep
inside the nuclei they struck without
bouncing back
they had to be uncharged the lack of an
electrostatic repulsion allow these new
particles to strike those nuclei with
great force a force that Chadwick used
to estimate their mass and he dubbed
these particles neutrons and quite
interestingly he discovered that they
were just a fraction of a percent larger
than protons themselves because protons
and neutrons are so similar in mass and
so much larger than electrons they
contribute nearly all of the mass to an
atom chemists use a unit of mass called
the atomic mass unit or am you to
compare masses of atoms to one another
and protons and neutrons themselves each
weigh just about one atomic mass unit so
this very convenient unit of measure
leads to a nice round number for
communicating the mass of an individual
atom so by 1932 the combined thought of
ancient Greeks Dalton Thompson
Rutherford and Chadwick and of course
many many others had led us to an
understanding of an atomic structure
that looks something like what you see
today in popular depictions of the atom
let's start with the simplest atom of
all an atom of the element hydrogen now
all atoms consist of that dense central
core of matter called the nucleus and in
that nucleus we always find one or more
protons and in the case of hydrogen we
have just one around that dense
positively charged core our electrons
and again in this case we have just one
electron to balance the positive charge
from the proton in the nucleus this is a
complete hydrogen atom complete with a
proton at the center and an electron
orbiting and we sometimes refer to this
version of hydrogen as protium because
it's nucleus contains just a single
proton now remember don't let this scale
fool you here I have drastically
increased the size of that nucleus to
make it easier to see if the atom are
really this size the nucleus would
actually be about the size of a grain of
sand but we need to see what's going on
here so I've increased it now it's the
proton count in the nucleus that gives
an element its identity so I can add a
neutron to my construct here and I still
have hydrogen but now my hydrogen atom
is twice its original mass so we call
this type of hydrogen one in which a
neutron is also present deuterium this
is more massive and protium I can
increase the mass of deuterium yet again
by adding another neutron to it to get
what we call tritium another form of
hydrogen and this one is three times
more massive than the hydrogen itself
the protein so all three of these atoms
are hydrogen but clearly they are
different from one another by way of
their masses when we have a situation
like this we call these groups of atoms
isotopes of one another so protium
deuterium and tritium are all isotopes
of hydrogen and their chemical
properties will be very very similar
even if their atomic masses are not we
sometimes distinguish them by writing
their elemental symbols with a
superscripted number to indicate the
mass of the isotope itself in this case
hydrogen one for protium hydrogen two
for deuterium and hydrogen three for
tritium now let's focus in on that
tritium
and let's put another proton into the
nucleus and change the identity of our
atom now that I've added another proton
to the nucleus I have to add an electron
to its cloud as well to balance out the
charge we now have a new element because
the number of protons in the nucleus has
changed we've taken our first step
across the periodic table to create an
atom of helium for add another proton
and an electron to balance it out we
have what would be called lithium five
but lithium is most often found with two
additional neutrons as well making it
lithium 7 this is the most common
isotope of lithium add another proton
and another Neutron and another electron
we get beryllium 9 and so on so we can
estimate the atomic mass of an elemental
isotope simply by adding up the number
of protons and neutrons in the
particular isotope for example a carbon
atom will always have six protons so if
I want to talk specifically about a
carbon atom with six neutrons in its
nucleus as well I would write its
elemental symbol like this the notation
for carbon-12 it's most stable isotope
if instead I have a carbon with seven
neutrons its mass is 6 plus 7 or 13 for
carbon 13 and again I can add one more
Neutron to get eight I now have a total
of 14 particles in the nucleus for a
mass of 14 this is the famous carbon-14
isotope used to radiometrically date
archeological finds this same notation
can be used for all elements take a look
at uranium for example all neutral
uranium atoms will have 92 protons and
92 electrons to balance that charge add
143 neutrons and you have uranium-235 a
relatively rare isotope of uranium which
is highly unstable and can shatter in an
instant making it useful for the
construction of nuclear weapons instead
add just three more neutrons and you get
the isotope uranium 238 an isotope which
radioactively decays but it does so over
billions of years
giving us a clock with which to measure
processes as old as the earth itself
there are many elements that exist in
nature as two or more isotopes in fact
most of them do and when this is the
case the periodic table will report an
average mass for a given element in
nature for example you may notice that
chlorine atoms exist in nature as two
different isotopes chlorine 35 which is
about seventy five point eight percent
abundant in chlorine 37 which is about
twenty four point two percent abundant
in nature a quick look at the periodic
table shows us that if we consider a
large collection of chlorine atoms
knowing the relative populations and
masses of the isotopes that make it up
the average mass of a chlorine atom is
thirty five point four five atomic mass
units just as the table reports this
doesn't mean that there's a fraction of
a particle in the nucleus it simply
means that there are multiple isotopes
that are abundant in nature so far we've
confined our discussion of atoms to
situations in which the number of
protons and the number of electrons are
exactly the same that's convenient
because they're opposing charges balance
one another out resulting in an overall
neutral atom but what happens when
they're not balanced as you might expect
when the number of protons and electrons
are out of balance we create a species
that carries a net overall charge these
charged species can have properties that
are drastically different than their
corresponding neutral atoms chemists
call these charged atoms ions and in
general if there are excess electrons we
get a negatively charged ion called an
anion if there is instead an excess of
protons we get a positively charged ion
which we call a cation for an example
let's take a look at the element
fluorine with nine protons and nine
electrons fluorine looks something like
this but if we add one extra electron to
it we get what's known as a fluoride ion
an additive sometimes included in
toothpick
you're drinking water to help strengthen
your teeth we can create an ion with an
even greater charge by adding even more
electrons consider oxygen for example if
we add two electrons to oxygen we get
what is commonly called an oxide ion
this is the form of oxygen that we find
in rusted metal for example let's take a
look at sodium now with eleven protons
and electrons we can remove an electron
from sodium creating a positively
charged sodium ion that charged sodium
ion not the neutral sodium atom is that
pesky form of sodium that your doctor
keeps telling you to cut down on in your
diet and just like anions cations can
carry greater charge when the
discrepancy between electrons and
protons is greater the for example
magnesium would have 12 electrons as a
neutral atom but when found in rock
forming minerals like limestone those
magnesium atoms are missing two
electrons forming a cation with a +2
charge so let's take a moment now and
review what we have discussed so far we
started out considering how nature uses
combinations of smaller simpler
components to create tremendous variety
in a wide range of scales from galaxies
to biological systems we saw how atoms
are not so different having only three
components called subatomic particles
protons neutrons and electrons we saw
how protons and neutrons reside at the
center of the atom in its nucleus giving
the atom most of its mass and how
electrons orbit that nucleus balancing
out the positive charge at the Adams
center then we talked about the ancient
Greek philosophers and their debate over
the most basic components of matter
which led to the coining of the term
atom meaning indivisible we saw how this
term falls short in describing atoms as
we know them today but it's deep history
in the discussion has led us to keep its
namesake for the building blocks of the
elements next we took a look at
how the work of John Dalton reignited
the discussion about atomic theory 2,000
years after it was first proposed and
how he did this by considering the law
of conservation of mass and the law of
multiple proportions
we then saw how the work of JJ Thompson
led to the discovery of the electron and
the plum pudding model of the atom and
how his protege
Ernest Rutherford bounced alpha particle
radiation off of gold foil coming to the
conclusion that atoms were in fact
comprised of a dense nucleus containing
protons two generations later we saw how
James Chadwick discovered the neutron by
investigating this unusual type of
radiation that didn't bounce off of the
atoms it hit but instead penetrated them
once we had our inventory of subatomic
particles we took a deeper look at the
structure of the atom we saw how the
number of protons gives an atom its
identity and how we refer to the number
of protons in a given element as its
atomic number we then saw how the number
of neutrons can affect the mass of an
atom generating what are called isotopes
we saw how the number of protons and
neutrons together is referred to as an
isotopes atomic mass and finally we saw
that by adding or removing electrons in
an atom's cloud we can impart them with
an overall charge creating positively
charged cations or negatively charged
anions
but what neither Thomson nor Rutherford
could possibly have known in their day
is that the cloud of electrons around a
nucleus is far from uniform it actually
contains a very complex system of
electron orbits and the position of
electrons within the cloud of an atom or
ion is one of the most significant
driving factors in how these elements
behave next time we're going to dive
deeper into this structure and
investigate the electronic structure of
the atom